yo big news big [ __ ] news this is
huge
ricky this is big [ __ ] news sales
with schultzy bro this guy this is
[ __ ] news bro you gotta take it
seriously you're not taking it
big [ __ ] news here um
pakistan beat india and cricket
let's go
let's go let's go my neighbors would
pack you up
yeah yeah you got to let him have one
you got it
who pakistan
india and india
yeah they're different countries no i
know i have pakistani neighbors you're
pakistani neighbors hey us too
we're gonna
no so the reason why this is a big deal
is because we have a podcast a real live
pakistani right here okay and we have a
real live indian right here they have
been mortal enemies for decades
big problems yeah lives lost over this
and a safe way for them to compete
without the world burning right
obviously where are both of them nuclear
powers
india is is pakistan they got slingshots
yes you have slingshots yeah slingshots
with marbles not the boxes okay so
there's no nuclear there's no they got
nukes they have news
so i mean we have two opposing countries
that are ready to [ __ ] blow each
other doesn't it look like they make up
that game as they go along when they
play yeah
back and forth
puerto ricans only allow one game with a
bad ball right yeah
[Laughter]
okay it's a broomstick cut off
now now this is a big [ __ ] deal yeah
okay is this embarrassing for you as an
indian it was bound to happen 12
straight wins for india
how do you feel about this i feel great
look we haven't won in a very long time
yeah so we got this one win and it's
it's good i got it i think we're turning
it around hey hey oh you think it's you
think it's over like his turn is done
hey
i would love it we got to compete in
something y'all are too dumb to win a
spell and be over here
we gotta have something yeah
[Laughter]
listen this is very serious ricky we
need you to chime in on this okay i'm
team india hey jesus oh
he's dead
yo they were hiding in [ __ ]
it's a problem for anybody that's me
searching in the back of my head that's
exactly what
i thought yeah
stop hiding people killing my people
yeah
yes who are your people
who are your people new yorkers
portuguese [ __ ] kids
sub-saharan
[Laughter]
okay but okay akash you were taking this
quite well yeah they had to get one yo
you now if we keep losing it's gonna be
a problem but you're taking this
too well to the point where it's
condescending
like you're like yeah you got to give
them a little something yeah yeah how
much could you watching huh how much
quick are you really watching enough
wait do you really watch the sport of
qriket i watch the world cup whenever it
comes around so you know that even my
idea friends were losing their minds and
i didn't even know but when world cup
comes around if we lose i'm gonna be
[ __ ] devastated and is it looking
like there's a chance falling i think so
because we are turning it around wait
can i just ask you guys one question
because i know you guys are real fans of
the sport you really care about yeah
qriket trivia let's go only watch world
cup can you name one player on the
pakistani not a single one [ __ ] fraud
you could can you name one of them
fact check that he
[Laughter]
last i knew he was the captain okay and
then ms dhoni i don't know if he's still
playing but he should be he's not
playing the last world cup he's not
playing anymore that guy was playing in
like the early times
all by themselves over there in india
imagine that being a chant in america
cowboys
it needs to be a longer name for him to
like
also have some
uh retired uh december 30th 2014. yo
you're a fraud
and you're a fraud not fortunate bro i
mean almost what is this he played him
so that's seven
just admit you know nothing you know
nothing jon snow i know
you know i know you're not calling
[ __ ]
coley verath v-i-r-a
have y'all you made them play each other
yeah we do yeah every single year yeah
we race them
[Laughter]
it's kind of fun we do we do we have a
brown race every single year
we have a fight to the death coming soon
listen
you gotta thin the herd
cooking come on now say what you want to
say yeah talk that [ __ ] talk that [ __ ]
say what you want to see you have my
food yeah
it was the only food that has ever woken
me up out of a deep sleep
[Laughter]
for good or bad reasons bro bad
it's the other one yeah it's like oh i'm
awake i'm smelling something yeah like a
boxer like that yeah yeah yeah like i
just got knocked out
i mean you're probably just not used to
seasoning
that [ __ ] it makes no sense
i live in williamsburg he's from
virginia oh so you're not from okay not
from
yeah but you don't have your wedding in
your backyard and [ __ ] like you know i
actually did but
if that's more virginia
no in queens they have it right in the
backyard you play the drums and stuff
and all that stuff i've been through
with a few of them yeah
all right
all right you might be a little
qualified
mickey just discredits people who are
not queens is the most diverse borough
no but i like the fact that you just
discredit him based on the fact he's not
from new york like if somebody came here
and they're like no no i have a new cure
for the chronovirus where are you from
staten island navy
is
you can't cook
that is true i like that article that uh
i think it was vulture yeah did where
you were saying they got me in my
feelings yeah yeah you were you were
scentsy you were a little sensitive in
that moment i was definitely like pissed
you off i just think it's weird some
comic pissed you wait what happened in
the vulture article he was just upset at
all you comics coming to new york
calling ourselves new york they they use
the city and they don't they don't give
it back i feel like they don't get it
because the city took from us so we're
good we'll call it even what does that
mean they said he just takes all the
time it's expensive [ __ ] cold all the
time oh yeah because you would be doing
this for a living yeah where you're from
no i had to be here but because
because why because it's the greatest
city in the world
yeah we'll see where you live when
you're 40. what
florida we all know
all roads lead to miami baby that was
actually really good that was really
good
i know why andrew spent exactly six
months down there
six months and a day
and a day
[Laughter]
only flying in through newark using cash
[Music]
but i was looking up that six months in
a day oh you didn't do it no i really
thought you were down there doing that
it's for it's hard we're talking about
uh cheating taxes yeah
not cheating not just cheating not yet
son new york got a tax office in florida
in miami for that reason they're
catching [ __ ] so if you're
there for six months in a day you don't
get to write out the whole year you just
get to write off what you did there
they're right okay during those months
so i'm like are we gonna stay here for
another two months to just be able to
write off the [ __ ] we did for six months
even though we're doing stuff podcasts
etc back in new york for the other six
like the money didn't work out but i was
looking into it cause i thought i found
a loophole i was like hold up so i just
stayed in nice weather for half the year
and then save all the money yeah and
then new york was like nothing